robert you are just such a brilliant
young man doing
really awesome things so good thank you
thank you so much you know i just feel
like i feel very very lucky that i i get
to
kind of have such an amazing family
around me and you know kind of
help keep this this legacy going that my
dad started you know i feel like all the
work that we do is
is so important i just feel like it's
who i am more than what i do
i'm gonna tell you bendy is one of the
sweetest brightest lights that i have
ever interviewed
in my life yeah she's i mean where do
you start
where do you start like she's just
honestly if you're on the phone with her
and you sneeze you'll get a bowl of soup
and flowers
honestly like she's just the most kind
just genuine person that you'll ever
meet and now to see her as a mum
it's just amazing she is such a good mom
and she's really
tried to now prioritize just time with
family she's taking time out with
of course chandler her husband and her
beautiful daughter grace and
for me being an uncle getting to be in
there and being involved
is just amazing and i never thought i'd
see my big sister
as a mum it's just a really surreal and
wonderful experience and
to have a new family member is just
awesome you know grace will be
in there swimming with sharks in no time
i think mindy wants her to wait a few
years first though
that's a few years because she's only
like a few months old right
yes yeah yeah how do you feel like
you're doing a
big uncle over there yeah i think i'm
doing pretty well
you know she is only three months old
but i'm trying to introduce her to
as many new things as possible she's at
that age now
where she's really reacting to things
you know when she sees a new animal we
met
a koala for the first time the other day
and her little face she was all kind of
sleepy
and she saw that koala and her face just
lit up
the biggest smile and it was amazing i
can already tell
she is a wildlife warrior i mean with a
name like grace warrior
mate she is going to be such a goer and
i i cannot wait to just introduce her to
everything zoo life
she she i'm already trying to teach her
how to play the guitar it's one of my
passions so
she'll she'll always go to sleep when i
play the guitar she loves it so you know
i'm
trying to be the the fun uncle funkel
robert
sounds like you're doing quite well
buddy that is for sure
now speaking of what i want i love
seeing in the special
there was a moment some vintage video of
you at about
with you and you're holding an alligator
and honey you could not be
any more excited and you told him that
that alligator just you were in pure
bliss
you know footage of your father the two
of you together
what is it like for you to see that
footage now robert
it's amazing it's it's so meaningful
honestly i i think that for me you know
of course
losing losing dad at such a young age
that's that's a tough thing to go
through and everyone will experience
grief at some point in their life and i
just feel very
lucky that first of all i had such an
amazing dad he was
of course a wildlife warrior force of
nature but
he was above all a dad he was the
greatest father he was
always there for bindy and i and his
passion was just to teach
us and and impart as much wisdom as
possible
and for me to have so much of my life
with him captured on camera
it's just wonderful because when the
memories start to fade you know i was
less than three when he passed away you
know memories definitely start to fade
but when i can have this whole archive
this whole
amazing set of footage i can go back on
i can literally just rewind press play
and relive all these these amazing
moments and it just kind of
re-sparks all of these memories with dad
and it's incredibly meaningful for me
and i i just feel
very very lucky very honored that i get
to continue this mission that he had
and i feel like you know it's never been
more important this message for wildlife
conservation this message
connecting people with the natural world
it's never been more important than
right now and i know that
if he was still around today i mean he
would be still
fighting the good fight as a wildlife
warrior and i would hope
doing things like this shark week
following in his footsteps
i hope that he'd be proud welcome
talk to me about shark week you've got a
special account for
shark week we are seeing you in an
entirely different light
but why are you so passionate about
going on out on these
shark dives from sharks
to crocs robert yeah well i think that
for me this
this adventure it was probably the most
amazing trip i think i've ever been on
you know for for so many reasons you
know first of all
from a personal note the reason why i
really wanted to
to be involved with shark week is
because sharks are kind of the the one
animal the one big
apex predator that i haven't really
worked with i've
gotten to work with everything from
tigers to of course crocodiles
all these amazing creatures but sharks
kind of
they were last on the list and they were
always an animal that i really wanted to
work with
they're an animal that dad loved so much
he always said
diving with sharks particularly with
great whites of course
it's the most moving experience that
you'll ever have
and so i felt like it was such an honor
to follow in his footsteps i was going
to
so many of the same places that he would
dive with sharks on his old
documentaries
so it was really special for me i
definitely felt really close to him
through the whole process
but of course for me my thing my passion
of crocodiles
and from a very young age since i was
just knee-high to a grasshopper tiny
little kid
i've been in there working with crocs
and now pretty much
every day i'm i'm working with them
feeding them
um you know working on crocodile
research crocodile conservation
i mean they're such a big part of my
life and honestly there's no better
adrenaline rush than standing in front
of a croc
striking out at you it's just incredible
robert even great whites could
at one point in time you're in a cage
and you are expecting encounters with
great whites
and your mama sweet terry she is on the
boat did she have any reservations about
sending you out there
she honestly i think after all the
adventures mum and dad went on
i mean she's just like go for it she's
the coolest mum
and to be honest she's done everything i
mean she's with dad jumping on crocs
she's with him
wrangling highly venomous snakes she has
been there since day one and so
for her i think it's really nice i've
got such an amazing and supportive
family
if i want to go out and you know have a
one-on-one experience with a great white
shark
she's right there just saying you know
what go for it was you're
this impressed with your shark skills
i gotta say there was a little bit of
healthy competition i reckon
she went and swam with whale sharks
biggest shark in the sea
and of course they're they're not
predators at all they're just they're
really like
whales they just get around eating
little plankton they're very peaceful
but i was so jealous you know when she
went and swam with them
i was very very jealous so when i could
finally do my own shark week adventure
um i may have made it gloated a little
bit saying you know
well you swam with whale sharks but i
was in with great whites
but now she was she was really really
proud and really happy and
you know i've i've always got such an
amazing sister you're taking on the
great whites
yes what's that yeah ah
i reckon ah after after taking on sharks
i feel like
the the world is my oyster now i reckon
i've i've got
crocs i've got sharks i think i'm just
ready to go and
i feel like going forward i i definitely
want to keep doing what i'm doing and
continue with
with uh being you know having this
platform and trying to
spread this message of conservation and
hopefully you know who knows next year's
shark week we'll be back with more
sharks you know i
i definitely just want to continue this
legacy that he started
and getting to work with discovery is
such an awesome
opportunity for me because that's that's
what what dad loved i mean
it feels like a family it really does
dad started on discovery and on animal
planet
and he always loved to work with the
crew there and for me getting to
to uh you know carry out his work and
work with the same team that he did
be back with our discovery family it
kind of just feels like
feels like we're home you know it's it's
really nice so i think there's going to
be big things in the future
and more action-packed adventures yet to
come this is only a small taste i reckon
there's plenty more yet to come
you